the whole climate change argument okay
once uh uh the AOC gets up and says you
know the world's coming to an end in 12
years and then your best friend the girl
you like the most uh Greta Greta who
just she's coming out with a new book if
I'm sure you ordered the degree bye I
love her yeah she's so Greta's got a new
book coming up about climate climate
change the best way to gauge if these
things are real climate change is go
talk to actuaries who run these big
insurance companies whose jobs is to
protect a billion dollars because one
thing insurance companies hate is to pay
out money they do not like paying out
any of their money and you know you
notice long term they don't have a
challenge but what's going to happen
with the market with climate change if
they did they would be investing in
different places the whole real estate
on the water what's going to happen with
homes in Florida if it's that bad why
are insurance companies you know
offering the insurance to these homes on
the water or else is it going to be an
issue 100 years from now probably is it
going to be an issue 50 years from now
probably is it going to be an issue and
next 10 20 years probably not so the
actuaries job is to sit there and
calculate risk everything's about that
so the Petro dollar the fiat currency
whatever way we want to put it
could that collapse uh could America go
through the mess they're going through
right now if we don't pay our debts the
biggest scariest number to be thinking
about is the following this is the
craziest number
in 2019 uh uh we paid 350 billion
dollars on interest of our debt in 2020
our debt interest payment was half a
percent we were paying 350 billion
2021 was 0.1 percent it went lower we
still paid 350 billion dollars in
interest 2022 last year our interest
went up to 1.9 average we paid 464.70
here's the crazy part just Q4 of 2022
Jimmy we paid 213 billion dollars of
interest just cute four at a 1.9 percent
average right now we're on a four and a
half to six percent run rate this year
this will be the first year where
America is going to pay over a trillion
it could be a trillion to a trillion and
a half we pay interest in interest in
interest only in interest only you're
already your debt is already climbing
heavily now add a trillion dollars of
interest and credit card payments in
America credit card debt in America's
943 Heist we've ever had it and savings
is declining last a month our savings
rate was 2.4 percent we're not saving a
lot of money right that's a 17 year low
those are the things to really be
concerned about on what's going to
happen with the market so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]